i'm going to jump around
a bit in this chapter
from how the textbooks got it's
organized because i want to show you how
different things are connected with each
other
different different passages so
let's start out with clarifying terms
antebellum before the war
uh and then evangelicals we've already
talked about who those are
and
revivalism and reform are two main
components of evangelical culture
yeah these like um
like the book is saying these not only
shape the lives of evangelicals
themselves but it becomes part of the
american character
so these are the people that when other
people look at america
and talk about those americans these are
the ones that they're taking as the
emblems around the time
of the early 1800s through the civil war
and
you can say that they had a common set
of assumptions
these these all had to do with
creating a christian american which that
culture
would be the dominant one
so
your book talks about theology and i'm
going to come back to that i want to
skip over that for
for a moment
and i also want to
skip over some of the discussions
of
the
common sense philosophy
and and some of the other
issues here and i want to jump into the
discussion about higher
education so
oops
yeah let's look at these things
what were what we're engaged in right
now higher education
this played a major role
in this development of evangelical
culture
we've talked about this a little bit
before the ivy league schools most of
them start out as religious schools
they're founded by particular
denominations
to
articulate and to train people in
that particular denomination of seeing
things
your book like runs through all sorts of
other schools
the ivy league they're the early ones
they're the ones who supply
the administrators for later schools
your book runs through a whole bunch of
different
we might say second-tier schools not i'm
not i'm not making you know a judgment
on whether they're second tier now but
at the time they would have been like um
denison
oberlin ohio wesleyan
um
wooster all these are actually started
by
by protestants
and they're intended to be protestant
schools
your book talks about capstone classes
how many of you are seniors right now
are any of you seniors okay
how many are juniors
so you seniors you're already thinking
about or working on your capstone right
and your juniors do you have an idea
what you're going to do for your
capstone
in your major no idea
some idea
what is a capstone class supposed to do
other than be some some impediment that
you got to get through to get your
degree and get out of here and get on
with your your career
what's the actual purpose of it
maybe supply a professor some reason to
indulge their
their area of research
supposed to tie everything together
right a capstone in a building
is the stone
that
connects everything else like in an arch
it's the art it's the one that holds the
arch together so it's supposed to be the
class that's bringing together
everything that you studied and helping
you
to synthesize that material
your book talks about who you actually
used to teach these capstone classes
it was the president of the university
so imagine that your capstone class is
with dennis murray
instead of with whoever is going to be
your professor with this and you know
what the capstone class would be is
moral philosophy
um and usually that would not just be an
ethics class like the one that you've
taken already here at marist
it would be much more religious in
nature it would tie together theology
and ethics higher ed was closely tied in
with
religion not just in
the founding of these schools but in the
very structure of the curriculum
it was putting across this kind of
um
viewpoint
and
it wasn't just higher ed it was also
what we would nowadays call primary
and secondary
education
these were felt to be particularly
important not only
in order to have an educated public
which you need for democracy
but also for religious reasons
if you want people to be able to read
the bible
they actually have to be able to read
right
if you want them to be able to make
decisions for themselves about what
their devotional life should look like
they have to be able to not only read
but able to be able to make sense out of
what they're reading we have to develop
the skills that we nowadays call
critical thinking
or
content analysis those sorts of things
and your book talks about this in terms
of literacy it talks about an entire
literature
that was popular at that time
not just the king james bible but also
the fox's acts of
or the book of martyrs
john bunyan's pilgrim progress
richard baxter is the saints everlasting
rest and all these hymns by isaac watts
and charles wesley these are not books
that we read much anymore today
but they were part of a literature that
educated people at that time were all
intimately familiar with
um
they were they were devotional
literature that people would use to make
sense out of their
their religious life
so
in the primary or secondary schools part
of the goal was to enable people to be
able to
make sense out of other things and
like your book points out this education
was publicly supported we're talking
about a public school system
the common schools could serve as a
conduit for non-denominational moral
training so i'm actually going to put
that term up there non
denominational
moral
training
so non-denominational that means
it's not tied to any particular church
if you go to a non-denominational church
you'll ask are you a baptist a methodist
will say we're non-denominational
we don't actually take a stand on that
sort of thing we just read the bible or
we just you know
pray or do this sort of thing and moral
training means um being trained in a
certain way of understanding right and
wrong
what we often do call ethics right
so that's part of what they were they
were doing in school it was as important
as reading and writing and
arithmetic
uh you could say that our
religion was the fourth
the fourth r involved in that but a sort
of just general protestantism
like your book points out they did use
the king james temple
for readings
and that didn't go over too well with
jews or catholics or
non-christians of you know
atheists
deists they they were not that big on
that
um
but it took a while before that that was
you know sort of rooted out
so all of this is
part of what's going on
there's another form of education that
your book talks about as well
the entire sunday school movement
which originally starts out as a way to
reach the poor
and evangelize
the the working class laborers
on a day when usually they're going to
handle off
becomes a way to
carry out this kind of moral education
among the middle class
among among protestants
so there's a like i said a vast
instructional literature that develops
out of this
and
you've got all these things connected
with each other who are
providing the teachers who are providing
the sunday school teachers quite often
the universities or colleges have a role
in that
these are connected with each other all
of this is sort of a vast network where
there's no one single point that you can
point to and say aha somebody made a
decision and everybody else is following
that decision instead it's more like
there's all these different ways to to
be a christian
provided you stay within certain
boundaries don't be a catholic don't be
you know later on a latter day saint or
things like that
but so long as you remain within this
this set of boundaries
you're fairly free to do what you want
your book also talks about the family
home as being sort of a shrine a
domestic shrine
and the role of of middle uh middle
class women
in the 19th century you see these
developments that take place that are
really quite
uh not unique because it's happening
also in england in germany
but it's not happening everywhere else
and
women
i think you've all heard this status
they're like placed on a pedestal
or they're they're cast into the abyss
um either they're like the the you know
the
chase goddess of the home
or their the uh
the street walker
that was sort of a common portrayal in
the in the 19th century if you read 19th
century literature
um
in part that was taking place because
for middle class women there wasn't a
lot of uh
engagement in the marketplace there
wasn't a lot of engagement in the world
of
work and commerce outside of the home
and so they wind up like your book says
isolated with their children in gentile
neighborhoods
far removed from from the cities
and a new cult of domesticity or true
womanhood begins to emerge among
american protestants and it influences
catholics to some extent
so
what does this take place uh in terms of
your book talks about
samplers bookmarks bibles pin cushions
you know we call these things these days
except for the bibles
knickknacks or kitsch you can still find
them in some old homes but for the most
part you're probably not going to
decorate your house with the kind of
stuff that 19th century
uh antebellum evangelicals
found to be completely essential these
were the things that that everybody who
is you know civilized would have
like it says the mother was primarily
responsible for the maintenance and
decoration of the home as well as the
moral and religious nurture of the
children
so they talk about this in terms of
domestic piety and that's that's a
central idea
so notice all the things that are tied
in with culture we've got education
we've got the home
now we want to look at the actual
religious practice and
beliefs that are tied in so we want to
look at
theology
and
worship
um
let's actually start with with with
worship
we're gonna use this term low church
which is usually used about anglicans
but it makes sense to use it in terms of
this low church or evangelical
worship is going to be
it's going to be less liturgical
more oriented
towards
devotion
towards preaching of the the gospel or
preaching of the
preaching coming out of the bible right
at applying biblical verses to
particular circumstances
and
it's going to be in certain respects
less less uh structured
so
revival preaching would be sort of like
an
extreme of this with a revival you don't
have any sort of liturgy going on
uh it's a necessary part of it you have
this incredible effort to awaken
enthusiasm in people but like we've seen
revivals they don't last that long
they don't produce
a lasting effects that that can be
continued
instead
what what's needed is some sort of
pattern
and the pattern
involves
what these are what are the basic
elements of evangelical church services
so there's prayer
and your book talks about this as
occasional they don't mean occasional in
the sense of like every once in a while
they would pray because they were
praying every every time they'd have a
service
instead it means that people would
compose prayers for the occasion
and sometimes they would recycle these
they weren't being all
made up on the spot spontaneously
these could become very dramatic
singing
and you know this is something that we
kind of take for granted most most
church services that you go to the
united states today
there's going to be a music minister and
there'll be a lot of singing because
people like to sing
and they you know there's a lot of jokes
about who sings well and who doesn't
sing well if you want to hear good
singing for instance go to a baptist
church if you want to hear mumbling
along with it maybe go to you know a
catholic church or unless it's one that
really likes to sing there's all sorts
of jokes about these sorts of things
right but
everybody does tend to have singing as a
matter of fact some of the newer
churches
that may be the centerpiece
of the service that's a pretty new thing
for for liturgical churches they had
music
but a lot of the radical reformation
churches
they narrowly restricted the kind of
singing and the occasions in which it
would take place remember with the
calvinists it should all be psalms and
they resisted any sort of songs that
would not be coming out of the bible
so this is something quite different
all sorts of singing is taking place
there's like a gathering body of
traditional by this time traditional
songs that people would sing think about
for example amazing grace all of you
could probably sing the first verse of
amazing grace whether you're a religious
believer or not right because you've
heard it so many times
you're going to lose hum i think you
might mumble some of the words
i bet you probably know that more likely
than knowing all the words the national
anthem
because amazing grace is still kind of a
more prevalent song
that was a new song at one point and
then it became part of a repertoire
and you know if you do these things over
and over and over again it becomes kind
of a habit
um
preaching
another central part
of the the the worship
and what is all of this
tied to
well um there's a few
main things that they're they're they're
focusing on in this champion that tie in
with this reforming impulse
uh and here now we're starting to talk
about the theology remember we began at
the beginning of the semester talking
about what is theology
it's the
more organized more academic way in
which people make sense out of what's
going on
in their religious tradition
it's it provides you with some of the
whys some of the deeper meanings of
things
um
you wouldn't necessarily have to do
theology to go to church
but somebody's doing theology somebody's
providing explanations
so the theology
there's sort of a
a spectrum between calvinism
and armenianism
john wesley and then there is like this
third way
theology and your book talks about it in
terms of these these two very important
evangelical figures who were talked
about in previous chapters but i didn't
go into much charles finney and lyman
lyman uh
beecher
and then this guy horace bushnell and
bushnell um
he's being influenced by the romantic
movement
that won't make that much sense to you
unless you know your literature and
philosophy
uh he was he was working to undermine
revivalism through his down playing the
boundaries between the divine and the
human and the promotion of the idea of
christian nurture so what does this mean
when they're saying that in the textbook
he is he's starting to develop a
theology where unlike calvinism where
people are fallen and you can you know
sort of strictly divide the save from
the dam
and god really doesn't have that much to
do with with
the
distorted culture in which we live
with this notion
the the difference between the secular
and the profane the sacred the holy and
the everyday starts to break down
and
a new idea starts to come on the scene
and he's not the only person to
articulate it
there's a word that we associate with
this that's particularly
important
in theology
it's a long
one millennial
post-millennialism
post means after right you guys all know
that what's millennialism
well
what is the millennia what let's start
with that what's a millennia
what does that mean
anytime you've got that mill
prefix
which do you think in terms of
give your hands it's composed of
centuries
put about put 10 of them together and
you got what
yeah so we're talking about thousands of
years
now
why does anyone care about that well
because
in the apocalyptic literature in the
bible so we're talking about the books
that are kind of murky and often seem to
be about prophecies
and people get into all sorts of
arguments about there is a discussion
about the coming of the second coming of
christ and
this was something that was very
important for early christians and it
was very important for for other
christians and when you get to like a
thousand year mark
like when it came to ad 1000 people went
went crazy
and a lot of people were expecting you
know the second coming and they would do
things like sell all their possessions
and just you know wait around we're
going to talk about some other
millennial movements a bit later on
now
with some of the ways in which this is
understood what's called
pre-millennialism
there's this notion that the second
coming is going to come
it's going to happen
coming it's going to come that's kind of
silly the second coming is going to
happen
and it's going to be preceded by all
sorts of terrible things happening
usually drawn from the book of
revelation
um and you know there's a lot of
discussions about exactly what's going
to happen who's going to be saved who's
going to be damned sometimes discussions
of the rapture get all rolled into this
as well
which by the way is coming from a
pauline letter
i remember right thessalonians
and this this
pre-millennialism
has this view that
things are gonna have to go to go to
crap before anything gets better
post-millennialism is sort of the
opposite
the view is that we're already in the
new age
and through human efforts
i'll put it to you like this
humanity
can bring about
something like
heaven on earth
as a matter of fact not only should
humanity do that or can humanity that
humanity should do that
that um
the thousand-year kingdom that's being
described in the book of revelation
would unfold gradually through
step-by-step improvement through
progress
so you know think about just
for example
material existence
let's leave religion out of it all
together
have human lives gotten longer and
longer
over the last 200 years why
hopefully i don't know that that's
actually true
think there's some studies that show
that that remains about constant
um but we're certainly living
differently what what are some of i
guess you could say we're living smarter
how are so much what are some of the
ways in which we're living smarter than
than say our ancestors were
i'll give you one really crazy example
my grandfather when he was a kid they
made him gargle with kerosene when he
got sick
now that can't be good for you
it might cure the cold
but it's going to kill a whole lot more
isn't it
and stuff like that was kind of common
uh it's not surprising they didn't live
as long we know more about what you
should and shouldn't do
i i hesitate to say that we're smarter
because we often don't put it into
practice but
um
we've gotten rid of a lot of diseases
right
nowadays people die of old people's
diseases for the most part like heart
disease cancer
back in the day you die of tuberculosis
or
malaria
and you could die pretty young from that
and we've changed that
um
we we do still have a lot of people
living in poverty but is poverty today
for the most part the same as poverty
was 100 years ago
there weren't any poor people 100 years
ago who had a tv
or
who
had a car
or i mean you could still be living hand
to mouth but but a lot of people are
living in in rather better circumstances
than before so that would be one example
of like you know bringing about this
heaven on earth we're not there yet
right
but that would be something that they
would be
driving at
so that's a major part of this this
entire to bring it up again this
term of the benevolent
empire
tended to be
aimed at
this notion that through progress we
would make the world into a better and
better place and that that was a
religious
uh expression and a religious
requirement
again something that you're finding
in in protestant christianity
evangelical christianity before the the
civil war
so your book talks about how all these
things are coordinated together and
here's where we actually get to the
question about like catholics that i put
off a little bit
your book also mentions that if you're
going to have some sort of drama like
this you've got to have good guys and
bad guys
so if you're the protestants
then who's gonna be the bad guys
not the jews because there aren't many
of them and they're not really doing
anything
there was a there's a lot of
anti-catholicism that was wrapped up in
this and as a matter of fact some of the
very documents that your book talks
about
later on they used the same stuff from
those documents and just changed the
names a little bit and that became
anti-mormon literature
anti-anti-catholic literature became
anti-mormon literature
and why well because you know you need
some sort of
uh
enemy
or or you know agent of evil
to to point at and that's part of what
they talked about here evil did not
exist as an abstract force but in the
very worldly personifications they also
talked about the slaveocracy
that meant the sort of southern regime
of justifying slavery and using human
capital essentially
just using it up over and over again
using human beings merely as as tools
but there was a lot of what they're
talking about is anti-catholicism you
can read about the literature in that
almost all that literature turns out to
be based on fiction
but it became very popular there's
there's a book by the way which i
recommend to you if you're interested in
this sort of thing called the protestant
crusade which is about precisely that
kind of
literature
so who would this be liturgical
protestants are mainly two groups the
anglicans
and the
lutherans remember we called them at the
beginning the conservative reformation
why were they conservative because they
held on to the liturgy this is why um
you can go to a roman catholic church
and a
episcopal church or continuing anglican
church and a lutheran church and you're
going to see a lot of similarities
between what they're doing at the
services as a matter of fact they may be
singing all
some of the same songs because they
share a lot of those in common with each
other they're they're all focused on
liturgy
so these are the protestants that
opposed to evangelicals
um thought that the way the service is
conducted needed to be retained and they
also so they're focused on liturgy
and to be focused on liturgy also means
to be focused on
sacraments
that sets them apart from from other
protestants quite a bit there's also
some some other
uh factors that are setting these guys
apart from other protestants as well so
they're not fitting in quite as well as
say presbyterians or methodists
in the case of the anglicans
it has to do with who's in charge
anglicans they're the church of england
right so
in the american revolution
who's the american revolution against
england and specifically
the king right
the king is the head of the anglican
church so if you're in america
and they're having a revolution against
the king who's actually the head of your
church you're kind of in a pickle aren't
you
and as a matter of fact quite a few of
the anglicans fought against the
revolutionaries they were part of the
tory militia
who were particularly strong in the
south where anglicans were found
that did not endear them too well to
other americans
and they were looked at as being kind of
suspect that's why they ended up
changing their name
from anglicans to
physical paleons
and they also sort of broke ties and
said the head of the english
church is not is no longer the head of
the protestant episcopal church in the
united states before the revolution
they were
in a certain respect the in theory
dominant
religious group in the united states but
they really weren't dominant they were
just sort of at the top as far as class
went
and they they weren't that influential
except in the mostly the southern
colonies
that's what chapter 12 talks about
and there was a lot of resistance to
them even before the revolution
as as things got closer and closer to
the outbreak of hostilities
anglicans were looked at as being kind
of like um you guys know the term fifth
column it's when you have enemies inside
uh your own country
uh people really who espouse the same
cause as your enemies living next door
to you that's the way a lot of people
started looking at anglicans people who
were going to become episcopalians
with lutherans it was a different set of
issues
with lutherans that he had to do with
ethnicity
um
where was martin luther
to start with you remember that
where does he nail the night i'm not
talking about like a specific town just
what country
where does he nail up the 96 95
saxony
yeah and now saxony was part of
germany right so a lot of ethnic germans
are lutherans
and then it spreads further north into
scandinavia so we're talking about also
it does go east to the baltic states as
well but not too many of them emigrated
so we're thinking about lutherans in the
united states we're thinking about
germans
swedes
uh
danes
and
norwegians i suppose you could say some
isil icelanders as well but there's not
a lot of immigration
from there
and they end up settling uh partly in
you know places like new york for
example once they're allowed to but they
also end up settling further up they
many of them end up on the frontier
remember when we looked at those maps at
the beginning of the semester where are
the lutherans where's the big presence
of them today minnesota is a huge
lutheran presence lots of parts of
wisconsin
iowa to some degree
the dakotas that's where you see a lot
of lutheran presence
why well that's that's where those
people settled
and when they settled there
like a lot of immigrants what are some
of the big problems for immigrants
besides people not liking immigrants
what are some of the
issues that they tend to
to bring with them
what are some of the challenges that
they face
to assimilating to the larger culture
so becoming successful enough to
be uh not just be a laborer or something
like that yeah
what else a language barrier that's a
huge one and those kind of go together
language and culture
before the
um
we're sort of jumping far ahead before
world war one
there was huge
amounts of german immigrants who had
never bothered to learn english
because they didn't have to because you
could live in areas where everybody
spoke german
there were parts of chicago like that
actually i knew a woman who grew up in
little italy
this was only about you know 70 years
ago she didn't actually know that the
rest of the world wasn't italian until
she she got to a certain age and moved
out of that neighborhood
and got a job and found out there were
other people besides italians because
everybody spoke italian and they had
their own movie theaters and their own
grocery stores and and it was that way
for
a lot of germans world war one changed
that because the germans actually not
only fought against us but had aspiring
in the united states and that ticked off
americans so much that um they started
forcibly requiring assimilation there
was the school that i went to as an
undergrad up until 1923 all the classes
were in german
that was a college
after that they switched to english
so
if you're going to do that you're not
going to blend in very well are you
you're not going to become part of the
larger culture and the larger culture
was
white anglo-saxon protestants this
evangelical culture of the benevolent
benevolent empire that we're talking
about for a while so episcopalians and
lutherans are somewhat in the same boat
they're they're not fitting in that well
they're both protestants
but they're not really
in the evangelical spectrum
there's some tensions that take place
having to do with how much to
assimilate
to
evangelical
practices
so your book talks about you know
we'll use this term low church um
and we'll use it for both
anglicans and for lutherans even though
it's not really appropriate for both
we're a little short on time so i'm not
going to go into the whole
uh
question here about you know the
eastern lutherans or stuff like that we
can use this term low church which meant
to have an evangelical emphasis there's
a lot of tensions because some lutherans
wanted to fit in better they they said i
kind of like what these other you know
methodist baptist presbyterians are
doing some of the episcopalians
especially in the south were doing that
as well
um this led to breakups this led to
splits there is a a southern
uh
episcopal church that split off
that's much more low church there are
lutheran churches
most of which didn't actually survive uh
as as as
holding on to their their
parishioners for very long but they did
the same sort of thing
so where we see groups like the missouri
synod coming in
are the ones that are favoring this
the traditional identity
um
and
what else do we need to say about this
this very quickly
um
some of this we can probably put off
till till a later uh class
along with the opposite of the low
church movement would be a high church
movement at least for the episcopalians
that's associated with what we call the
oxford movement but we'll look at that
in a later chapter so this is enough for
for right now